[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
well there's already motions in the
court
Jack Smith has already made his move
make sure Donald Trump cannot publicly
disclose Discovery they can't share it
can't publicly show it we'll see what
happens you definitely know this guy is
going to put Discovery out into the
public there's no question about it
I mean
are we supposed to believe
that Donald Trump is not going to be a
vile sack of [__] a heap of garbage and
not disclose information that's not
supposed to be disclosed but I think
that's what this whole [__] thing is
about isn't it
isn't it the reason why he's the only
former president who hasn't been able to
maintain
his class fight Clarence speaking of
that we're gonna have a special guest on
the show today
Fred Wellman is going to join us
of on Democracy pod and he's gonna give
us an idea of this classifying
information I I wanted to get someone on
to ask him about this someone who has
um Clarence said we're gonna have him on
um we're I've reached out to Major
ogetta we're gonna probably have him on
as well to talk about this
but I have a lot of questions
I had a lot of questions about
the right Wing's argument
but their arguments
their arguments are gonna get smashed to
Pieces here as this judge grants this
motion to Jack Smith
to
not be able to disclose any of this
discovery and they can't share it and
they have to be under supervision as
well from what I understand
it only shows the severity of what the
information actually is that he was
so recklessly holding at his hotel slash
house slash [__]
slash worn out Golf Course
and Mar-A-Lago
it only [__] spells it out even more
of why it's so important that Jack Smith
and the special counsel brought this
indictment in the first place
again
you can prove it Trump is going to prove
it
why this case should be brought
it was brought and it's going to be
prosecuted eventually now my my real
guess is here with these latest filings
and some of these motions in the back
and forth this is going to be delayed
delayed delayed delayed and it's going
to be delayed into a situation where
Donald Trump is going to win delegates
um they can't they can't get out from
underneath Donald Trump at this point
there's no there's no end in sight to
the absolute battle uh over the weekend
Chris Christie
question why the [__] should I give
loyalty to the nominee when the only
thing that the rnc's Loyalty pledges is
to protect Donald Trump and the loyalty
to Donald Trump
the [__] should I give that to him for
so Chris Christie tries again tries to
throw another punch I don't think he
lands it with a [__] Bill Barr lands
punches though this weekend holy [__]
listen hey Chris
hey Chris if you want to know how to
land a punch on Donald Trump you might
want to be paying attention to what Bill
Barr is saying and how he's you know
roughing him up a bit taking him back
behind the wood shed and spanking his
little ass cause God damn yeah I know
Bill Barr fan that guy is a that guy is
a pile of garbage he is a Nazi piece of
[__]
but son of a [__] that fascist
[__] over the weekend man
he kicked Donald Trump's ass on the
Sunday shows
but he'll still vote for Donald Trump
he'll still vote for him because he they
always give caveats right it's always
like oh he's the scummiest person I've
ever met in real life like I would never
leave a 10 bill on the table and him
alone in the room alone wouldn't happen
I would be afraid that I would come back
and my ten dollars would be gone and he
would steal it because he's a petty
childlike man baby who's a [__]
criminal and a thief and a crook
but I liked his policies
I liked his policies
any and he says it like it is okay maybe
that's the [__] problem right
maybe that's the problem with Donald
Trump I don't know maybe I'm off my
rocker here
but Bill Barr definitely would vote for
that [__] again you think
absolutely he would Chris Christie's
going to too
oh you [__] twisted Chris Christie
even though he's like I'm not giving my
full loyalty pledge like the RNC wants
to get on the debate stage
I I would imagine that that they're all
gonna give loyalty to Donald Trump
right
for this debate and then Donald Trump
ain't even gonna show up
and he's not gonna take the pledge he's
gonna say [__] you I'm not taking that
pledge
and he ain't gonna show up and debate
him
and then he's gonna go on fraud social
and talk about how oh well they were
nothing without me
and his [__] cult will blindly follow
him into the abyss good [__] him
good [__] him I'll say it again
what what else what else do they want
from us look we've been telling you for
[__] years that he's a loser and he's
gonna make your party lose over and over
and over again what I mean I'm I'm tired
of
[__] telling him this [__]
how [__] unpopular he is
there's people talking about a new poll
today that has Donald Trump and Joe
Biden neck and neck you dumb [__] it's
June 19th 2023
what the number one none of your polls
are gonna be worth a [__] anyways okay
they're just not polls aren't worth a
[__] anymore until you figure out a
different way to pull people We're not
gonna believe that garbage it's all [__]
none of them are right they weren't
correct in 2022 they weren't correct in
2020 or 2018 or 2016. they just weren't
[__] correct
so why would we listen to them now on
June 19th 2023 but the media is like her
man's headlines Trump is just as popular
as Joe Ben yeah okay No One Believes
that garbage
I mean it depends on what part of the
country you're in you might find 50 of
Trump trump support but it's rough even
in Trump country
it's gonna get rough even in Trump
country to find people who are
enthusiastic about a guy who's got 34
felony counts in the state of New York
for business fraud his business Trump
organization was [__] found guilty of
17 counts felony counts of Fraud and
fined millions of over a million dollars
which it should have been way more than
that but that's just the maximum the
judge could give his CFO went to [__]
Rikers more than likely a CFO is going
to turn on him in the [__] felony
case in the Manhattan DA's office where
he's charging 34 felonies then he's
charged with 37 Federal felonies in
South Florida for the Espionage Act
for stealing our documents and
obstructing justice when we wanted them
back we the government through Nara
wanted our [__] National Security
information back where it was supposed
to belong it doesn't belong to you dummy
National Security information is not
your personal papers
you buffoon that's what Bill Barr said
this weekend I'm going to show you the
clip of Bill Barr of course I'm going to
how can I not show you the clip of Bill
are absolutely burning him to the
[__] ground and pissing on his ashes
and then be like yeah I'll vote for that
pile ashes
I what he didn't say vote for him but
you know he would
you know he would he he
[__] defended and and protected this
fool while he was in office you think
Bill Barr has ever liked Donald Trump
if you watch how billboard talks about
Donald Trump you would know that that
[__] never liked Donald Trump
from Get Go day one
never like that some [__]
he was just willing to protect him
because he loves fascism bar
loves fascism he [__] loves it and
they see Donald Trump as the buffoons
tool to a fascist state
[__] that's why Rhonda santis for for
years mimicked him
now Ron DeSantis isn't doing that that's
why Ron DeSantis is so [__] weird and
he's different right
than it was even six months ago it's
because he's had to throw away the whole
Trump impersonation thing right he's
lost weight he didn't wear the stupid
oversized blue suits with the red tie
and your handmations and the Cadence
he's lost all of it he changed his hair
even for a while there and he's changed
it back
he has to reinvent himself because he
can't be too Trump trump 2.0 because
they're he's not really Trump 2.0 he
can't sell it as that because Trump 1.0
will win because he's the cult leader
and they're the cultist and they're not
going to vote for the non-cult reader
meatball
oh pudding fingers they're just not
there's not so he has to reinvent
himself but even he's not doing the
Trump impersonation anymore
he's not pretending to be Trump
santis what makes you think Bill Barr
ever liked him DeSantis doesn't like him
Bart didn't like him he's just a tool
all he is is a tool for the fascists to
advance their Nazi agenda
speaking of Nazis there's a video of uh
I don't know where the hell this was at
but I've seen a video this morning on
Twitter Nazi show I think it was New
Hampshire was it
was it New Hampshire is Connecticut
I think so I don't I don't know exactly
where this was at it was at a story hour
with with people dressed up in drag oh
and Nazi showed up and they're yelling
and screaming through the bookstore
window or the library window whatever it
is I don't know we'll see what you find
it and show it I love I love pointing
out Republican Nazis did you know did
you know this if your if your ideology
lines up with Nazis
and you're pushing the Nazi agenda that
they're going and protesting at Story
Hour children's story hour because
people are dressed up in costumes
reading to Children teaching them how to
read your your if you're with those
Nazis you're a Nazi that that's what you
are
man I mean you may not think you're a
Nazi but the [__] Nazis they think
you're a Nazi
oh man that's a shitty position to be in
and I'm just saying
why why would you why I mean look if
you're wondering who's the fascist in
this country when they do that you're
like oh Jim baden's division he's a
dictator he's a dictator wannabe and all
you Liberals are fascists
if you want to know
who the fascists are go ask the Nazis
like the the ones carrying the flags
and given the [__] Nazi salute and
saying Hal Hitler go ask those folks who
they like politically
and then you'll know who the [__]
fascist are dummies [__] out of here man
you think the Nazis like me
I mean he called me a fascist in the
Nazi all you want go ahead I don't give
a [__] but the Nazis are never gonna
agree with you like the actual Nazis the
actual neo-nazis they [__] hate my
guts
hate my [__] guts okay that that
probably is a good indication
then I'm not a Nazi
and that you are oh [__] they just don't
get it though they don't get it
they don't get that Donald Trump is the
cult leader for the cultists now again
you gotta you gotta get this in your
mind right to figure out how this is all
gonna go down
you gotta and it's tough because you got
to compartmentalize stuff
in politics right you can't you can't
hold these things personal you really
and you really can't look at them uh
through a lens of your own experience
right can't do that you got it you gotta
make sure that you're opening up your
eyeballs that you can cease
what is happening through someone else's
experience here's what I mean there
aren't cultists out there we've seen
them in videos where they got the Trump
shirt on the Trump hat they probably got
a trump flag they probably watch oan or
Newsmax [__] non-stop every once in a
while turning over to Fox News they
probably figured out how to get on
Twitter to watch Tucker's new video and
they haven't been able to get back on
since
they love book burnings they love though
they love to hate on the lgbtq community
[__] pride month [__] rainbows [__]
transgender people and [__] Bud Light
and Target right like that type of [__]
right cultist I'm talking about 100
cultist there's nothing you're gonna do
to undo the delusion that they have in
their minds they're deranged
they live in an alternate [__]
reality and that's really the lower
percentage of this country right 10 12
it's a lot of [__] people I'm telling
you it's dangerous I'm not I'm not
trying to minimize it or anything look
there's not that many people
percentage-wise in the [__] Trump
cult it's just not gonna exist then you
have the other people who look at the
Trump cultist and they're like you know
you're [__] crazy but we kind of
believe what you believe
oh those [__] they're not
they're not dead set they're not a
hundred percent on Trump but they're
gonna vote on him if he's gonna win and
if it appears that he's going to win
based on affiliation
which is noise right these these are the
ones who watch Fox News that don't
necessarily partake in the news max or
oan
they're not Alex Jones type crazy right
they're [__] Sean Hannity type crazy
right
it's like uh it's like a Nazi light if
you want to you know
put a little taste to it
now that's a larger percentage of the
country right that's the country who's
still rooted in white supremacy speaking
of white supremacy here on Juneteenth
but that that that is the the
institutionalism of white Christian
nationalists in this country right
the Christian Church the American
Christian Church no matter what uh uh uh
sect it is the American Christian church
has done a good job at convincing
the white Institution
of white Christian nationalism
to really perpetuate these ideas right
and it's not that it's not that they're
Trump cultists necessarily again we
gotta compartmentalize this thing
I mean they'll vote for Trump they'll
put a trump flag out in their yard right
but they would consider voting for
another fascist they would consider a
non-trump
authoritarian like Ron DeSantis probably
not going to vote for him because he's a
[__] weirdo and everyone else that's
yelling and screaming wants them to vote
for Trump
that's probably about 20 percent
right maybe 23 of the country it's a lot
of [__] people
so where are we at so we had 10 12 we
got 20 23 percent right we're at about
38 percent
35 maybe 40. if we're counting hard
now there's another five to eight
percent of the country
that would would love to please their
friends
in the in the other lower percentages
right and they would love to please
their friends and vote for Trump
that's that's the folks that we need to
get to stay at home that's right we're
going to have to suppress the vote I
said it oh Tony you can't say that you
can't say that liberals want to suppress
the vote bull [__] [__] we can't
why not
we don't want that we don't want people
who vote for [__] vile awful pieces
of garbage like Donald Trump Lauren
bobert Matt gatch Marjorie Taylor green
Paul gozar you don't want those people
to stay the [__] home
on Election Day you goddamn right I do
go sit down sit down sit this one out
you've caused enough trouble
and that six to eight percent is where
that can happen
that's where that can happen
because he's only he's only gonna pull
43 to 46 percent of the country right in
this General
and the reason why is because of
affiliation they're going they're going
to nominate a criminal
they're gonna do it
and people like Bill Barr and people
like Chris Christie are going to say
well
I can't vote for Biden so I have to vote
for the Republican nominee
and it's already they're already having
the discussion and they it's June 19
2023.
they're already having this discussion
in and amongst themselves and having
loyalty pledges
to do this
that's what old fights about anyways
they're trying to pull the Loyalty away
from Trump and it's not working
that's what they're having a hard time
with
because there's no one else Ron DeSantis
is a [__] weirdo he's not he's not
he's a [__] weirdo and again
one of the reasons why Rhonda Santos
appears to be a weirdo is because Ron
DeSantis has had to reinvent himself and
the reason why is because Ron DeSantis
invented himself into a trump
impersonator and when he had to go
against Trump and I asked to undo that
so now he has to invent this whole new
[__] character in Ronda Santa's just
doesn't have an idiom
he just doesn't
so that's why they're trying to seek out
this ability to chip away at Donald
Trump and his support that's why Bill
Barr goes on the Sunday shows it ain't
because Bill Barr's trying to save the
country folks it ain't because Bill
barrs woke up well oh man Trump is bad
for democracy
[__] out of here
these people have known Donald Trump was
bad for democracy the whole time that's
the feature
of the Republican Party in the
Republican nominee being Trump
it's not a side effect
that's the point they want Trump to
destroy democracy they want to destroy
democracy that's what they want
and if you don't know that by now that
their main goal is to destroy our
[__] democracy to take it away from
you well then fine you're an idiot
whatever it's your right to be stupid in
this country it's your right to be dumb
it's your right to be delusional we just
don't have time for you
happy
happy mixed feelings I'm going to talk
about Juneteenth for a second here real
quick uh before we go to the break at
the top of the hour we're gonna have
just as an announcement at the top of
the hour we're gonna have Fred Wellman
on the show he's the host of uh uh uh on
Democracy pod on the minus touch Network
and we're going to uh have him on I
wanted to talk to someone about
classified actors we're going to bring a
few people on to talk about this
um Fred is the first one to have on and
we're going to discuss you know the ins
and outs of classification and what it
means to be classified and declassify
can you reclassify what does it mean if
it's NASA security information what's
the difference
but I want to talk about that so we're
going to have Fred on to talk about
classified documents so stay tuned for
that at the top of the hour here in
about 36 minutes we'll have Fred on
don't change the dial as they say on the
radio the radio
ow let's go back to Juneteenth because
I'm a little mixed about Juneteenth
right A lot of people are I think
um it feels like
that some believe that the federal
holiday Juneteenth is capitulation which
to some degree I think that it the
appearance of it makes it capitulation
right
um the juneteen teeth has been
celebrated for decades in this country
by black people
they celebrate Juneteenth they knew what
Juneteenth was I didn't know I didn't
know what Juneteenth was and the reason
why is because I'm white and I grew up
in White America and they didn't want us
to know what the [__] Juneteenth was
they didn't want us to know what
happened in Galveston Texas when the
feds rolled in on horses and said hey
you've been freed for a while
[Laughter]
you've been free for a while
it's a wild story it's uh it's and we
should we should know that truth in this
country
everyone should know that truth in this
now a lot of again
I believe that Juneteenth um should have
been a Federal holiday a long time ago
there's uh Juneteenth there's a much
better use of a Federal holiday than
some of the others that we have
but a lot of people see Juneteenth as a
capitul capitulation
um
a virtue signaling if you will
which again
because these [__] idiots out there
these fascists get so get so upset about
the fact that yes we should celebrate
Juneteenth now rather it should be an
actual federal holiday I guess I guess
you could have that to be right but
we've already had the debate they've
already made it
a federal holiday
it already is one right
but
I think
I think that the fact and even if people
who celebrate Juneteenth don't like the
fact that we made it a Federal holiday
just as an attempt of maybe virtue
signaling
I believe I believe it's still worth
knowing the truth and I believe it's
still worth celebrating
in this country
that the last of the freed slaves
finally found out that their freedom has
been given to them
their Liberty had been given to them
in front of another hundred years
of Oppression in the South when they use
the Jim Crow laws
to subvert the liberty and the rights of
black people in the South and all around
the nation really and to Institute white
supremacy
in the 20th century
to make sure that there was two classes
in this country
there was the the institution of white
supremacy to make sure that whites had
the had the advantage and they do they
still do and if you don't know that if
you don't know the history
then go [__] read it
and on a today like today on Juneteenth
that's what we should be doing
we should be celebrating
that our country did the right thing
but it took us a long time to get to the
right thing is what we should know and
we still are working to get to the right
place
in this country
and Juneteenth is
is a holiday that you can learn both you
can talk about both you can celebrate
you can also
you can also mourn on this holiday
so I have mixed feelings about
Juneteenth
I have mixed feelings about it being a
Federal holiday I don't want it to be
part of history that it was capitulation
or virtue signaling
I want us to have the discussions I want
people to know the truth that I didn't
know that I wasn't afforded the truth
because of the institution of white
supremacy in this country that's what it
is if you don't know that then you're
not up to speed yet of why you didn't
know what Juneteenth was until it became
a Federal holiday and if you're upset
if you're upset because you believe that
well don't they have a month in February
too well then you're a [__] racist
bigot
got it do you follow me are you okay
you're gonna you're gonna be all right
there sonny you're gonna be all right
it's gonna be okay you're gonna make it
through this federal holiday just like
you made it through do the rest of them
[Laughter]
oh boy oh boy happy Juneteenth happy
pride month I want to give you a promo
code
uh it's it's the middle of the month we
usually do hat week but we're gonna do
something different this month uh since
the chat recommended the uh Miss
loveseat in the chat and the chat said
yes that's what we want and we did the
[__] em logo in Pride colors uh we have
a special promo code so listen up here's
the promo code it's Pride the promo code
is Friday at 15 off at store not the
Tony michaels.com that's Pride promo
code Pride at store dot the Tony
michaels.com and you can get 15 off your
entire purchase in the store so if
you've been waiting to get a discount
code for the store
here's your chance 15 off everything in
the store stored at the Tony
michaels.com use the promo code Pride
I'm so glad it's Monday I'm so glad
you're here let's go watch some videos
someone said the radio I did I say ragio
this is a radio show [__]
the Tony Michaels podcast right back
right after this
[Music]
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with these
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
oh man news news news
it's flying everywhere
it's like uh
Donald Trump and his legal team
[Music]
you're gonna have a rough time I think
with this decision that's been handed
down this morning have you seen this uh
let me see if I can pull it up here I
had the documents yeah here we go minus
touch at him uh here's the here's a
filing this morning this was made by the
bench magistrate this is the one that
arraigned Donald Trump so judge Cannon
didn't make this
um decision she uh it says Canon here
but Reinhardt is the actual one that
made this decision this morning and it's
a protective order and what the
protective order does is it protects the
discovery materials
um all non-classified here is what it
says definition of discovery materials
all mine classified Discovery uh
produced by the United States as the
defendant in preparation foreign
connection with any stage of this case
are subject to this protective order and
may be used by the defendants of Defense
counsel solely in connection with the
defense of this case not for any other
purpose and connection with any other
proceeding without further order to this
court now the the what the idea is here
is that Trump can't post this on true
social
like that's that's what they're [__]
worried about like Jack Smith is worried
and Donald Trump is just going to start
[__] posting Discovery online or he's
going to start having people go on TV
and start saying it or he'll say it in
his stupid little hostage videos that he
does or his little stupid statements
that he puts out that he's just gonna
start divulging the information that's
in the case
the the issue with this the reason why
this is uh so pertinent is number one is
uh even the non-classified discovery is
that if they do divulge it out in public
it could weaken the case against anyone
else that Jack Smith wants to indict in
superseding indictments in this
documents case right the other thing too
is the weird idea that we have the valet
and he's still his personal valet and
that he is that won't NADA because if
you see here
on this protective order it's not just
for Donald Trump it's for his
co-defendant Walt our Walt teen as it
that's his legal name waltin
okay that's weird isn't it yeah I mean I
would figure that if you're if your
nickname is Walt that your full name is
Walter not Walt team I've never heard
that before but you know what you know
who am I to judge
but uh walty NADA is on this protective
order as well now this was granted
almost immediately it seemed like uh
from Judge Reinhold now again Judge
Reinhold is the bench judge the bench
magistrate that um
oversaw the arraignment of Donald Trump
uh and Canon has deferred to Reinhardt
on some of these uh first motions and uh
again this protective order being one of
them that special counsel Jack Smith has
won here
[Music]
um
uh
here's another part here's part three
I'll read this to you Discovery a
disclosure of Discovery materials
defendants and defense counsel now this
is important not only can Walt nor
Donald Trump
um use this information a certain way
their attorneys cannot so Donald Trump
can't say well I didn't say that my
attorney said it on TV right like yeah
it's not a defense that's not going to
be defense
so what Jack Smith is trying to do I
believe is try to box in not only Donald
Trump with his St with his chaos machine
strategy because he definitely has that
strategy here of a chaos machine but
also I believe that there he's they're
boxing in the defense Council right so
the defense counsel can't somehow
subvert attorney-client privilege and
start criming with Donald Trump or he's
leading them to Crime
um they're really boxing them in here to
make sure that the the council that
defends Donald Trump follows the [__]
rules
follows the rules not obstructs or
tampers with Witnesses or materials
because it goes on to say defense
counsel shall not disclose the discovery
materials or other contents directly or
indirectly to any person or entity other
than persons employed to assist in
defense which is important persons who
are interviewed as potential Witnesses
counsel for potential Witnesses or other
persons whom the court May authorize
disclosure so in other words they're
saying hey
any of the [__] you see that's for your
that's for your production of your
defense that's it [__] that's it you
can't share it you can't say it directly
or indirectly if we find out you're
leaking this information which I would
imagine that they're gonna set up
like a skiff for this discovery now most
federal Discovery
um from what I understand in almost all
federal cases most Discovery and has to
be done at a certain area you don't just
get to go gathered up or they email it
to you it's not how Federal Discovery
works you have to go rediscovery and
take the time and it cost a lot of money
to pay lawyers to go look at the
discovery
General
in this case a lot of this stuff is
either National Security information
classified or could be classified
information
it's just [__] that you don't want
Normal public out there to see that's
one reason why we have Fred on today is
to kind of break this down so I'm kind
of glad this order came this morning
now number four of this uh protective
order goes into copies of Discovery
material it says defendants defense
counsel and authorized persons shall not
copy or reproduce the discovery
materials except as necessary to prepare
for defense copies and reproductions
shall be treated in the same manner as
the original Discovery material so in
other words
if you're copying it you gotta keep it
the same as the original
the original copy
um now they're not going to be able to
not let these people take notes
um it I mean that's just what they're
gonna have to do because regardless of
what you want to have happen to Donald
Trump right you want him to end up in an
orange jumpsuit or jail cell or
you know whatever you're whatever your
fancy is on this
it's very it's very important that you
understand that he should be afforded
the same legal process that you should
be able to be afforded when they say
well if they come after Trump they could
come after you yeah if they come after
you you damn right they should be able
to come after Trump but here's the thing
is if you're afforded the ability to
defend yourself so should he and if he
can you definitely should be able to so
let's keep that in mind here
um I mean I think he's guilty as Sin but
you know
we'll see what the courts say
we'll we'll see what the jury says and
again I keep telling you that we're the
we're the most important jury because
you won't likely see a jury in a
courtroom until after the election we
are the jury that will vote on him first
his conviction that is okay number six
of this protective order
I think this one's pretty important
um and I think this is the one that
Donald Trump is gonna [__] up
right like this is where he's he's gonna
[__] this up folks no way there's no
[__] way that Donald Trump isn't
gonna [__] this up
he's 100 gonna post something it may not
be like a picture or a copy of something
but he's gonna post [__] that they've
got he's gonna put it in a true social
post over there on fraud social and he's
gonna let the world see the [__] that
they got he listen
the only reason why this indictment
exists anyways
it's partly because of Donald Trump
I actually believe that even after the
search warrant right
I actually believe even after the search
warrant that happened at Mar-A-Lago when
they went to get their [__] after him
and Walt played musical classified
documents right moved them from one room
in this room and that room and this over
here and this over here
to the bathroom to the stage to the
window to the wall
to his Destroyer to the to his his
wife's underwear Gerard to his safe
around and around around they go
right they move these documents around
so no one could find him
I believe I believe that Donald Trump's
the reason why we know about any of this
and the reason why there's an indictment
is because even after that he didn't do
a deal
he didn't do a deal
with doj why didn't he do that deal
think about this for a second
think about this
if he did not do a deal then or if he
would have done a deal then I think he
wouldn't have been indicted even after
the search even if you'd be like all
right okay all right I get it I get it
you're gonna come in take the [__] the
FBI's involved you guys want to
investigate me cool I'll let you just
have all the [__] just take it all do
your thing I'm not gonna say anything in
public I'm not gonna cause chaos I'm
just gonna let the process do this thing
that way I don't get charged with a
crime like that was his last point
but when he [__] went on like they
raided my house and they took my [__]
and they took my passport remember all
that I mean for weeks he would say I
Declassified them with my mind I they
weren't classy classified which didn't
matter in the first place because it had
nothing to do with the classified by the
classification of the documents and
that's due with the National Security
implications with the documents and
they're not his they're they're not his
their hours
they belong to us the government the
people their hours
they were done under the office of the
presidency and even Bill Barr says that
in his clip but watch this here and
number six of this protective order it
says no disclosure to the public right
they even have to spell it out hey don't
don't
let this go public it says the Discover
materials along with any information
derived there from that's important
listen to that any Discovery materials
so documents or pictures or whatever it
is that they have in Discovery
transcripts tapes video evidence
security cam footage whatever the [__]
it is right because there's going to be
a lot of Discovery materials quote
materials
um along with any information derived
there from meaning if you figure out
something from the discovery and then I
don't know you and you post it somewhere
that's not going to work because it
shall not be disclosed to the public or
the news media
are disseminated on any news or social
media platform without prior notice to
or consent the United States for
approval of the Court
do you think
that Donald Trump
is gonna be on his [__] on true
social after he gets off the phone with
his attorneys and they tell him this
[__] or he gets out of a meeting with
his attorneys he shits his drawers he's
got to go change his diaper and he's
rage tweeting from the toilet do you
really think do you really think he's
gonna hold back this is gonna be the
worst part of this for Trump folks this
right here this [__] no disclosure to
the public this number six is really
gonna kick him in the in the balls right
it's really going to kick him in the
balls
now there's also another number eight
here I think is important it says return
of Discovery materials it says within 90
days at the conclusion of all stages of
this case including all related appeals
all discovery materials and copies
thereof shall be destroyed by the
defense counselor turned to the United
States unless otherwise ordered by the
court I think a lot of people are going
to get this confused this doesn't mean
it's 90 days from now this is 90 days
from when the case is finally closed and
all the appeals are done
then the documents have to be destroyed
and returned
by order of the court from the defense
Council so this isn't a 90-day order
this order is to to conclude 90 days
after
after all the appeals have been made
which folks again I'm telling you this
isn't going to go to trial anytime soon
and if this order is just one indication
of that because
oh my God he's totally gonna [__] this
up he's totally gonna [__] up number six
man he's there's no way and read it like
this is written for Donald Trump
that's the best part about this in this
protective order like this is gonna be
like they're gonna study this protective
order
in law school like this is going to be a
case study
in in our in our law schools in this
country and the reason why is because of
number six right here because he's
definitely gonna break this man
no [__] way is he not gonna break
this protective order
now rather judge cannon at the time you
know if judge Cannon eventually takes
over these motions and these rulings
which she is not so far she is um
she's defaulted to Reinhardt to make
these decisions on these particular
first motions in these particular first
disc protection order specifically
but number six man is gonna I I think
this is gonna be big history written
down in number six here let me read it
again no disclosure to the public it
says the discovery materials along with
any information derived there from shall
not be disclosed to the public or the
news media or disseminated on any news
or social media platform without prior
notice to and consent of the United
States or approval of the Court
you can't write a better [__]
paragraph to tell Donald Trump shut the
[__] up but do you think that's gonna
stop him I mean he has the right to
remain silent he just doesn't end the
[__] ability
I have no confidence
no confidence
that this guy's gonna do this now I want
to show you this here
uh just so you see this it is it was
done by judge Reinhardt the magistrate
who uh arraigned Donald Trump and again
Canon is uh and I'm not sure the actual
legal term of it McCannon is on this
order but she is what uh Reinhardt makes
some of these
um decisions on these orders and the
reason why is because they're still in
West Palm Beach
or excuse me in my in in Miami wait no
this was in Chambers in West Palm Beach
I don't know [__] I don't know that's
that's where my knowledge of attorney
stops okay
I'm not an attorney what do you want
from me what do you want from me
um here is the uh
here's the clip of Bill Barr trying to
explain once again
to the nation now this is on Face the
Nation with Bob Acosta here Bob was
filling in and I actually like Bob Bob's
one of the ones that kind of [__]
doesn't do the the nonsense where he's
like well I gotta I gotta see non-biased
so I don't want to appear to be biased
to the truth so I gotta capitulate to
lies he really doesn't play that game
much every once in a while but Bob's
pretty good I don't know why Bob doesn't
[__] host some of these shows on
Sunday in the first place he's guest
coasting here
um but let's let's listen to Bill Bart
tell the America again how [__]
stupid
Donald Trump is you say Trump's alleged
conduct is indefensible so many
Republicans continue to defend him what
will it say if the party your longtime
party puts him forward as their nominee
well that's the problem I don't think
they're actually defending his conduct
but they are saying it's unfair to
prosecute him but that then raises
another question okay if it's unfair to
prosecute and that's not the whole
answer
the question is should we be putting
someone like this forward as the leader
of the country leader of the Free World
who's engaged in this kind of conduct
okay so let's not there Bill Barr you
[__] scumbag you defended this
[__] this isn't the first time he's
acted like this
this isn't the first time that he's
shown that he has these traits or these
or this personality or defects of
Personality whichever one you want to
say that he's a [__] man child and
he's dangerous
Bill Barr protected him all the way up
until Bill Barr couldn't because Bill
Barr would have went to a Goddamn
federal prison for what Donald Trump
wanted him to do
about the election in 2020 and and just
overturn it and make him the dictator in
King as if Bill Barr had that power
come on man this is why I keep telling
you look this scumbag keeps coming out
he keeps trying to damage Trump he's not
going to do a very good job at it
I mean I mean he's the only one really
swinging and hitting to be quite honest
I'm going to show you a clip of Chris
Christie hearing a little bit talking
about
um the Loyalty Pledge of the RNC debates
Chris Christie's trying man he's really
he's really trying but he he's he's not
as good as he once was
Chris Christie that is Bill Barr's
Landing the best punches I mean Bill
Barr's Landing better punches than some
[__] Democrats damn better than John
Bolton is landing I mean John Bolton's
trying to but with no success Bill Barr
though
he's swinging he's hitting uh but the
cult doesn't care let's listen
the other thing is this is not just an
isolated example Trump has you know has
many good qualities and he accomplished
some good things but see see you see
what I mean you see what I mean
you see what the [__] I mean
it's a caveat it's cat look look he's a
[__] bio piece of trash but he's a
vile piece of trash that believes the
vile garbage that I believe
come on man they're gonna vote for him
any [__] out there still
standing around wondering why I keep
saying Donald Trump's gonna be the
nominee it's what Bill Bart just said
it's the caveat every time they date to
try to attack him again Bill Barr's the
only one that really is swinging hard at
him
really trying to bloody him up but it's
always with the caveat of oh well you
did such great things and he believes
that I believe and he says it like it
you know those [__] stupid bad stupid
[__] capitulation they give to that
fascist authoritarian but let's listen
but the fact of the matter is uh he is a
consummate narcissist and he constantly
engages you knew this you knew this
you [__] piece of sludge you you've
known this the whole time we told you
this Hillary tried to tell you she tried
to tell you she tried to tell you
you didn't [__] listen because you
don't listen to anyone
really honestly that's the problem that
Republicans have is they really don't
listen to anybody
they don't listen to the [__] the
other leaders on the other side of the
aisle they don't listen to to people
like the market
is telling them when target post Pride
stuff when it seems like the entire
um corporate apparatus virtue signals to
pride month is that to some degree what
it is well a lot of them are genuine in
their celebration of pride
come on man they're trying to tell you
they're trying to tell you and you won't
[__] listen you won't [__] listen
even to the market you won't listen
what's going on
and then you won't even [__] listen
to yourselves you won't even listen to
your [__] selves
oh God
just a reckless conduct that that puts
uh his political followers at risk and
and the conservative and Republican
agenda at risk would he put the country
at risk if he was in the white house
again he will you notice how he said
that there
and and Bob caught him on that right
and he's basically saying he's putting
his political followers at risk because
[__] the people who who are our enemy
Bill Barr is the same guy that says look
it's the winners who get the to write
the history
right
the quiet part out loud look the reason
why we don't know the reason why white
people in this country only knew what
Juneteenth was in 20 up until 2020 was
because white people won and white
supremacy won and we own the
institutions so we were the ones who
rewrite history that's what critical
race theory is is supposed to do is to
undo some of that tell people the actual
history of the country so that you can
you know know the truth
Bill Barr such a scumbag I just it's
[__] hilarious when the [__] sandwich
eats itself
right when you watch in the [__]
sandwich eat itself oh my god let's keep
watching them eat themselves always put
his own interests and gratifying his own
ego ahead of everything else including
the country's interest there's no
question about it this is a perfect
example of that he's like you know he's
like a nine-year-old defiant
nine-year-old kid who's always pushing
the glass toward the edge of the table
defying his parents to stop him from
doing it it's a means of self-assertion
and exerting his dominance over other
people
and you knew this
and you're St you know it
right
so why not just burn him to the ground
end it it's enough already it's enough
the reason why
because people in this country are
[__] bigots they're racist they're
fascist they they want the fashion they
want it they want the fashy it's that 10
12 percent of the cult that's brainless
that doesn't know that's what it is
right there's probably about five or six
percent and it's in their in their side
that is driving this garbage they know
it's [__] they know it's fascism
they know they're Nazis but they push it
anyways Bill Barr's one of them Bill
Barr is one of them he'll vote for Trump
and he's he's a very Petty individual
who will always put his interests ahead
of the countries his personal
gratification of his you know of his ego
but our country our country can't you
know can't be a therapy session for you
know a troubled man like this
come on come on you gotta hand it to
Bill Barr even even this scumbag has got
some good zingers on Trump right
come on you gotta admit it I mean he he
threw a lot of good punches there
now will they land doubt it
I don't think they will
I mean this morning Grandpa's [__]
freaking out on true social hates this
[__] yesterday today absolutely
losing his mind
couldn't even hardly put out a decent
Father's Day message yesterday he
couldn't he couldn't oh by the way Happy
Father's Day to everyone who was
celebrating Father's Day yes yesterday
we had Father's Day and day we have June
Juneteenth
oh boy
[__] crazy ass [__] isn't it oh let's
see we're gonna have Fred Wellman here
in just a few minutes
um let's see if I can find
um
let's see I had another clip I wanted to
show you
oh um damn it
okay I'm gonna show it I don't give a
[__]
uh let me see if I can find the
different one though is that the one I
want Jon Stewart finally um came around
to the two-tier justice system thing you
know I've been saying here for a long
time on the show that mogulodites are
really [__] pissed off they've been
pissed off and they've been yelling and
screaming too too that's the system
there's a two-tier justice system
boohoo two-tier justice system is what
uh the mongolites have been yelling and
screaming right
now
um because of that I said from the very
beginning when they started saying that
you goddamn right there's a two-tier
justice system in this country
yeah there's a two-tier just and the
reason why
moglodytes and Trump is so mad they're
so [__] pissed off is because the the
second tier the privileged tear Donald
Trump's privileged tear is no longer
protecting him
it's what I said
it's what I've been saying since the
beginning uh now there's a lot of
there's a lot of uh and we didn't show
this this was posted the 15th so this
was posted uh Thursday I believe so I
didn't show this the other day now this
is the problem with Jon Stewart not not
he's got a problem that's the show the
show is called the problem with Jon
Stewart
Ed it's a problem with the show called
the problem which is see here's the
problem with John Stewart you know what
I mean the prop the show is called again
quote unquote the problem with Jon
Stewart but the reason why I can't if I
show it
um Apple Apple TV is gonna [__] do
their copyright thing right oh that
[__] Apple defends their [__] like
crazy
like others like NBC CBS uh there's a
lot of places that defend their their
content
um as with copyright
but I'm gonna show it why not and just
to show you what John said this is two
minutes of Jon Stewart but see if you
can catch what he's saying here about
the two-tier justice system
um here and before we get a break let's
listen Trump has used privilege and
wealth to protect himself from legal
accountability at every turn he has
lived his entire adult life in the space
twitched illegal and unethical he's in
the tier where you get the Platinum
arraignment package no cuffs no mug shot
all you can eat fingerprint ink you
think regular people get to surround
themselves with a neat Shield of
henchmen to go to prison in their place
okay so Jon Stewart is obviously talking
about the two-tier justice system that
does exist in this country and again
I've been saying this the reason why
Maga and the reason why Trump is so
pissed off not at a two-tier justice
system that's not what they're mad about
okay they're mad that their privileged
tear Donald Trump's privileged tear is
no longer protecting him to the degree
that it's protected him his entire life
that's what they're upset about no I
don't think anyone on the left or with a
couple brain cells to rub together is
disagreeing that there's a [__]
two-tier justice system in this country
obviously there is there has been for a
long time ah isn't it isn't it crazy on
Juneteenth that we're sitting here
talking about two-tier justice system
and it's manga who is mad oh there's a
two-tier justice system in this country
oh thanks for finally waking up dummy
but you're mad at the wrong thing you're
mad you're not mad that there is a
two-tier justice system you're mad that
you're orange deity the the orange
Mussolini Jesus the Cheeto dust q and
honor Grandpa Poopypants himself is not
protected by that tear a privilege
anymore it seems but John's right he is
protected he was afforded a lot of
things he didn't have to fight he
doesn't have travel restrictions which
any other [__] American who is
charged with 37 felony counts on the
Espionage Act my guess is they wouldn't
let that [__] go anywhere but
the [__]
that would be my guess in a in a [__]
holding cell somewhere
but let's listen to John and then we'll
go to break but if you really want to
know what tier Donald Trump is in let's
look at an actual fraud we know he was
guilty of he used his own charitable
Foundation like a piggy bank or as it's
sometimes known embezzlement shocking
pattern of illegality including unlawful
coordination with the Trump presidential
campaign repeated and willful
self-dealing and much more he stole from
his own charitable Foundation how much
more could what did he also not punch a
priest like
how are non-trumps punished for
something like that well some get two
years in jail some get five years in
jail some get 10 years in jail for
stealing from charitable donation and
that's the point is yes there is a
two-tier justice system but you idiots
you morons you cultists you mygas sheep
are mad that it's no longer protecting
Donald Trump the way that you need it to
protect him to continue to be your
authoritarian little dictator everyone
stick around we got we got Fred Wellman
we're going to talk about classified
documents I want to ask him several
different questions number one what is a
classified document and can you
magically just declassify it with your
brain the other thing I want to know is
if you can declassify with your brain
and and your superhero Presidential
Power can you reclassify it that way but
more importantly I want to distinguish
the difference because manga doesn't get
it I don't think what the difference
between classified and National Security
information is so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after this
break with Fred Wellman we're going to
talk about classifying documents
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day years Tammy
[__] um
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show I got a special
guest for you here today we are going to
talk about classified documents or
non-classified documents depending on
which brain magically Declassified them
or not or maybe reclassified I don't
know I got several questions we've had a
lot of questions about classified
documents here on the show since Donald
Trump uh committed Espionage that's what
we know so far allegedly uh but we have
Army Combat veteran and host of
on-democracy pod on the Midas touch
Network Fred Wellman Fred welcome I'm
glad to have you on the show Good to be
here brother how are you oh well I you
know better than I deserve and even if I
complained I don't know that anyone
would listen well maybe a couple
thousand people but you know they
probably start to drop off Fred
I I got it I gotta tell you I have a
million questions about classified
documents because I'm I'm I've never
actually had a clearance to have
classified documents or classified
information have you before done this
with had uh experience with last my
documents I guess that's where we should
start first so what's your experience
with classified documents and tell me
why you think it's so important that um
I don't know classifying information
should be somewhat protected
I have a lot of experience so I I got my
first topsier clearance uh after Desert
Storm so in 1992 uh and then I held the
top secret compartmentalized information
or special formalized information uh
clearance it's all retired pretty much
in 2022 so I uh they're 2010 sorry so I
I bought in 18 years I had a clearance
or so so I'm pretty intimate with it I
even had a job that was my job was
actually managing our classified
information program so I've I've got a
lot of experience with the documents and
what goes into them and you know have
them in a skiff and all those things so
so yeah it's it's a shock and
essentially there's three levels of
classification in our system which is
also not true but you're going to find
it's like a rabbit hole but confidential
secret top secret
it's secret top secret you've got
information that can be specially
compartmentalized beyond that that's
where you may have heard well Walton
outa opened a doc opened a closet found
spilled documents they actually rejected
we have a we have a picture of it we
have a picture and that was a five eye
so that was that was special caramelized
five eyes what that means is it can only
be shared with five countries U.S Canada
England
you know so so you can't normally have
it um in a bathroom at a hotel yeah
okay okay I'm just making sure just
making sure yeah yeah all right I want
that so it's weird but I mean yeah you
have these are these are typically in a
skiff there's a classified facility it's
a it's a vault I actually worked at a
skiff for a long about a year after 9
11. tell the audience what a skiff is
specifically because I think there's
some confusion around that too yeah
exactly and you see I I margin likes to
muddy that stuff up too so
um it's the compartmentize information
and facility that's what it means scif
and that is where we keep these
documents it's not fancy it's a vault
it's a fancy fault it's got sound
proofing in it it's got It's got wiring
so you can't you know get cameras in
there and stuff like that essentially
you can't you know x-ray it with
anything that an enemy would want to do
to try and find out what information is
in that facility uh it's not fancy it's
it's just room uh you go in I worked at
skiff in Atlanta after 9 11.
um you know five lots of filing cabinets
the special you know special copy or
everything everything in the episode is
classified right the printer is
classified so you can't you know you
can't just move it in and out it held
the chairs are expected to make sure
there's no microphones it's all the
outside you can have open conversations
about this classified information that's
why you see a lot of the congressman
talk about going into this gift for
briefings it's all it's designed to be
soundproof it's designed you can't have
microphones uh before you go in you have
to put your cell phone in a in a
compartment you know you're not even
want to bring your cell phone in I mean
it's the whole idea we have an entire
system entire massive apparatus designed
to contain information and ensure that
it doesn't leak to our enemies uh and
and get out and and and so the
discussion of you know can he hand
looking yeah obviously he's the he's the
commander-chief he's got access
information there's a lot of confusion
you know Trump lost his clearance it's
like a congressman Trump they don't
actually have clearances per se if they
had a clearance what happens is that
process is an entire background check
you fill out what's called an sf86 it's
it can be a massive document with
references all the way back to when
you're in [__] kindergarten he didn't
do that is what you're saying say again
he didn't do that is what you're saying
because he would automatically be given
clients because he was the president of
the United States his article two power
right he's the he's the top right no
he's not going to do it now people work
for him supposed to that's where you if
you remember the beginning
Administration there was some you know
Jared Kushner didn't pass right they
didn't want to give Jared Kushner a
clearance seems seems weird I don't know
well here's and that yeah it all comes
together doesn't it so oh my God
now there's Gabe Sanchez hey what's up
brother yeah so hey Kushner couldn't get
one so he could yeah but Trump doesn't
get one but by the same token the minute
he walks out of office he's no longer
has clearance right now in the past the
out the form the replacement president
would say hey he can still have daily
briefs and certain but you know Brian
said nah bruh
we're good we're good we're good so you
know he has no access so so let me let
me ask you since you brought up my
because the right wing I I mean uh me
and Gabe go in these Twitter space this
is where these um these [__] these [__]
boxes well hey a lot of times we like to
go in there and we really like to upset
them we got two white men this week
There's this one's always inviting like
nah bro I'm not no Tom Finley might be
the one man yeah oh yeah it's probably
the one we go to and we got Seb gorko
pissed off at us he doesn't like he
doesn't like us and he definitely
doesn't like that guy with the last name
Sanchez it's really that's what he said
but anyways
they they talk about a lot of stupid
[__] right and they talk about it in
ways that that sounds great if it were
like in a Jason Bourne movie right but
this isn't a movie this is real [__]
life okay and in real life the president
United States can't just think something
uh like declassing the document and
years later months later say you know
what I thought about that years ago and
it was Declassified like that's not
exactly how it works they say that's how
it works but if it's how it works let me
give you a few examples if this is how
it works number one maybe I'm off my
rocker here but when Joe Biden the
minute the second that he became present
when he swore in when he had his hand on
the Bible Joe Biden could have thought
all the documents that Donald Trump has
that are classified that he Declassified
that were once classified now they're
reclassified now it seems like there's a
more um uh a more formal process the
class find this information than that
but it also seems like there's a more
formal process process to declassify now
I want to take this one step further
because they're always yapping about
Hillary's emails right they brought it
back up Hillary's emails there's a
private server in a bathroom really
there's [__] classified documents in
Trump's bathroom okay we got pictures of
it it's not complicated stuff but what
if Fred just follow me on this what if
Barack Obama when he discovered that
Hillary Clinton had these emails in a
private server right
what if Barack Obama used his mind okay
because he's a smart guy I'm sure he's
he can think things he just thought in
his mind but he forgot about it he's
forgot about it until now right but he
remembers hey I thought way back when
that all the emails that Hillary Clinton
had on her server were classified I
thought they should be Declassified so
they're in in lies the problem that the
Republicans had because now me as Barack
Obama remembered that when I was
president and I had the power to
declassify these documents I magically
thought it which made it so which means
you can't prosecute her doesn't that
sound really stupid that sounds really
stupid every defense you've seen is
stupid right it's right and we're really
good we're with band your mind we did we
didn't even talk about nuclear
information so by Statute so Congress
passed a law so so Moses classification
system is Guided by executive order
correct now neither Trump nor Biden yet
have updated the executive order from
Bill uh Barack Obama which is kind of
funny that the law that is getting uh
Trump in trouble is actually written by
Express because he was too [__] lazy
and updated but that's near here and
there you know because the other thing
we are as [__] up as Trump is he's
also monumentally [__] incompetent uh
and so thank god um but having said that
is exactly work now where it gets really
interesting is with nuclear material so
anything to do with our nuclear programs
our stockpile weapons the way they work
that's actually governed by the nuclear
regulatory agency in partnership with
the Department of Defense and that's
called restricted restricted information
if it's formally restricted that means
DOD and uh the atomic agency said hey we
need to access this information so we
get so the Air Force can drop these
[__] bombs whatever you know what I'm
saying and so but that's classified but
that classification and restricted and
formally restricted and then under top
secret is controlled by law by Statute
that the president cannot declassify
that like it's actually so so whoa whoa
well wait a second because that is that
is not that is not what these these
Twitter lawyers say these Twitter
lawyers say that the president United
States has unilateral power to
declassify anything he wants no matter
what it is at any moment the president
United States either now or acting like
they did with their mind years ago can
declassify
yeah and I can tell you for a fact that
Tom Finn personally told me on a Twitter
space that this is not in fact how it
works he said that Donald Trump could
declassify whatever he wanted so I don't
know I mean put the cute games you know
they could play cute games executive
orders all day but that's not how the
process works and there's a good reason
that but before I get to that several
documents that were in those 300 plus
documents they had classification organs
were Atomic related they weren't that
was the issue right we were taught by
nuclear weapons Iran's nuclear weapons
so let's just set everything else aside
say five of those let's just say five of
those can't be Declassified even with
his mind powers and his orange [__]
Spanish
he's still [__] I mean reality winner
reality winner went to [__] jail for
five years for four pages a doctor four
pages right so he'll say he got five
class you know again so setting all the
[__] aside there is a system in
place for these declassifications you
have to notify these agencies because
they when you declassify anything
there's a reason you go through a
process to do it because us it's not
meant to just you know give out stuff
let's just say I mean let's say it's a
war plan in that war plan is where we're
going to put our troops what ports we're
going to use you know the deals and
think about how you could use let's say
we had a war plan I'll say I don't know
Iran I don't know if you guys know
Iran's the other side of the [__]
world from us we don't actually have
direct access to draw on but friends and
neighbors do we would want to work with
those friends and neighbors to have
access in case of War think about Iraq
and Turkey right we went through turkey
for Northern Iraq and what happened if
you remember your history because I
don't think you guys are born there in
2003 in 2003 what the [__] wait how old
do you think am I wait a second friend
wait a second how old do you think we
are thanks to you but we're driving
we're driving
we like to Hash things out here Fred
Gabe what year were you born
89. I'm a little older than Gabe so we
we may look young people flying
we were eating we were eating Cheerios
you see that [__] art there that ugly
ass art right there yeah um
[Laughter]
says I died jest uh but we digest so
having said that if you remember we
couldn't get through turkey because
Curry said [__] we're not letting you
in and so the point I make with that is
let's say I don't know who's near Iran
Saudi Arabia
and let's say Saudi Arabia had access to
our classified War plans the Iran and
let's say Saudi Arabia found out those
War plays that part of our plan
Logistics part of it was using [__]
Saudi Arabia really yeah who leverage
why why why wait a second friend why why
does Saudi Arabia why is that
significant why is Saudi Arabia
significant right so why would that be
helpful to an ally you see the thing
that happens it doesn't even have to be
your enemy per se that needs this
information a friend and let's say our
friend wanted to leverage that to hold
us you know not not you know let make
sure we still give them nukes let's say
they want to have their nukes of their
own they could take this information say
hey look you want to [__] have a war
and use my port well the price is going
to be five nuclear weapons have a nice
see I'm saying so right how much do you
think then wait wait how much how much
do you think that information might be
worth the subject two billion dollars
really is it
that sounds like a pretty that sounds
like a pretty brown number two yeah it's
a billion dollars right it sounds like
and so
yeah so that's that's the thing people
get whatever in the house I saw some
maggachud on [__] Tick Tock or you
know on uh on chuds of tick tock um on
Twitter just now going you think a
president who oh yeah I thought it was
make America great would would give in
to me our enemy stuff maybe not but he
sure as [__] would give it to the Saudis
because he loves his first trip as
present with Saudi Arabia can you pull
that clip pull that clip information
yeah he gave a golf tournament to Saudi
Arabia he [__] got you look the
Saudis could use this information just
as much as our enemies well you can
almost argue where they are on me but
here we are so classify information
there's layers to it then we talk about
the means well now we're telling our
enemy how we collect information do you
think the Iranians would want to know if
we've got a [__] spy inside the
president's office those are the things
that are in these classified documents
and and the discounting and what really
makes your brain banned is a guy like me
who used to be tattooed Republican I was
a republican voter I never worked with
it professionally but I was a voter I
was I was a defense Hawk and and to see
the party go so far off the [__]
rails that they're making excuses for
hundreds of classified documents just
being tossed on the floor of a shitty
golf club or Beach Club a moldy ass
[__] beach club in Florida like
yesterday's [__] and so the whole
thing's ridiculous and then the National
Defense that you were talking about
you're a pretty one you know National
Security information see that's your
part Trump's big defenses these were his
personal papers right if it was even if
he Declassified it this is where it gets
really funny even let's say he magically
did declass all this [__] [__] but if
it once had a classified marking on it
it's not a personal paper it still
belongs to the United States government
classified Declassified National
Security so that's one of the reasons I
think they charge them use with missing
National Security information even if
they really were all Declassified
magically using his [__] you know
Dutch Annie lotion
the thing is it doesn't matter because
it's still U.S government properties not
look he can bring [__] headlines home
he can get a picture of him you know on
his knees with [__] Prince of Saudi
Arabia that's personal but when it says
classified it's government document and
so what other arguments are [__]
[__] and the punch line is they're
going to go through all these nut rolls
they're going to get dismantled to the
[__] Court it'll take [__] forever
uh but but you know this is all just a
silly [__] well that that's that's a
good lead into the question because I've
been trying to prep my audience here for
a huge disappointments of trial going or
Donald Trump going to trial before the
election there's no way he's going to
trial before the election in the
Manhattan case in this case the D.C case
the Georgia case they're all going to
um make sure to defer to the American
people because we are the jury at this
point I believe we are the first jury
that's the system though brother I mean
the system alone I read article today
because this is a classified because
this relates to classified documents
this there's this the sipa cipa [__]
thing yeah yeah because it's classified
information there's a handling process
for the classified information
processing and whatever anyway so that
there's more preliminary emotions they
have to go through so just it takes a
long time for someone to go to jail
period Steve band's not going to try off
in her [__] year okay throw in a
classified documents it could be it
could be two years and and it makes
people crave makes me crazy
um but it is what it is it takes a long
time Gabe did you have any questions did
you did you pull that chud of tick tock
no I'm I I'm dealing with my own [__]
internet problems yeah I can tell so
like I can't oh are you simultaneously
yeah yeah so I was late I was recently
nothing worked yeah yeah no what was it
what I was gonna say go ahead Domino is
going to make the comment I was gonna
make on the classified uh documents is
you know it's uh it's almost as if
there's a process as you said that you
would have to go through to classify and
declassify documents it's like I don't
know there'd be uh a group of people
that might have to be in charge of said
things you know instead of one person
just
thinking it with their hand and waving a
permanent marker and being like poof
it's Declassified but no I I it's
interesting to see
um
Maga you know like the video that that
Tony's gonna pull up the one that you're
talking about in the car the guy's like
why would a billionaire have to sell
it's like he's not he's not rich he's
not a billionaire the guy with the
glasses in the backwards hat yeah yeah
of course yeah every single time and it
just it is not American
right and and I mean it's it's hilarious
it's hilarious and sad every time I
watch these videos I'm like God damn how
dumb but I will say this I did read an
article or the study that was done in
2020 with a white supremacist where they
gave him MDMA
and he reversed his views and questioned
his own thought process and this weekend
when I read it I was like
can we just drop this in the water
supply somewhere
Capitol Hill like look I'm not this is
you know for for the FBI agent watching
this show right now it's all a joke okay
for legal purposes it's a joke but what
if in some alternate reality somebody
did just happen to dose Capitol Hill
yeah I'm just saying a lot could be done
well right yeah well I mean just yeah
that's the guy right there yeah here it
is let's let's watch this um since you
referenced it a few turds on the left
even realize that the indictment
requires Donald Trump to actually commit
Espionage this is how [__] stupid the
media thinks you are that you're willing
to buy that a billionaire who didn't
even take a [__] salary while he was
president is somehow selling classified
information to other nations whose
slogan is literally make America great
again and America First is somehow
working for other countries did you know
hey Fred did you know that um did you
know in the 1920s and 30s in Germany
Nazis called themselves socialists did
you know that
and obviously obviously it's not an
authoritarian dictatorship where he
murders his own people obviously they
call themselves something that's right
the name right exactly you can't you
can't go against the name so I I gotta
it goes also the presidential records
act right like they don't read the well
it's called the Prezzo record he's
president so it's his record that's
right the law it's like that's not what
the [__] law actually the law says
the opposite of what he's saying it says
the opposite of what he's saying now
here's the thing
right I wanna I wanna ask you a question
because the audience wants to know this
um okay
um
do you think all that's coming out will
change the minds of GOP service members
I know you said you were a voting
Republican before you're you're you're a
veteran do you think that this
information is going to start to chip
away at his support of service members
yes
yeah look so you guys should know my
background I was a Lincoln project guy
right so when I joined the Lincoln
project I was I was in charge of our
veterans and Military pillar and if you
remember I always tell the story a lot
but we had people misunderstand what
Lincoln project was doing our mission
was to Chip Away Republicans didn't
voted for Trump the first time you know
and we figured out actually Steve called
we called the Bannon line Steve Bannon
gave a speech once he said look you got
to take these Lincoln project guys
seriously because they're able to
[__] chip away four to six percent of
Republicans that voted for Trump the
first time we lose and so that was
literally we had posters made of the
Bannon line I have one I want to get I'm
gonna hang it right hang in here and it
was the picture banned with the band
online and the van lies that was so as
far I was I was I was at dinner one
night and park city was a friends of my
neck I think I don't understand you link
a project guys you know what you you I
don't get you they're liberals I'm like
great you're not my target I don't
[__] care you know right
my job for the general election campaign
before I became executive director was
uh veterans and so I ran and me my
friend Kurt bardello was his idea
actually we ran ads on stars and stripes
we ran out of military times we thought
I was crazy actually running
anti-presidential Trump president Trump
ads in a military newspaper but my goal
was to say look this guy does not
represent our values this guy doesn't
respect our lives I mean the whole
suckers and losers thing I piled the
[__] on that stuff because like this is
not a guy I only need to peel away
foreign and this is where I go back to
the discussion of trump being elected
again look if you think a normie
Republican who voted for the first time
is going to see a guy with 34 accounts
in New York 37 counts Federal 17 counts
of his company being corporate fraud you
know and then on top of that stealing
our most classified documents treating
them like [__] continue to treat them
like [__] no he's going to lose and he
doesn't have look the problem in our
world we all people I do politics for
living I'm like you know I'm a
strategist and and people always look
for the big move I need to move 10 20 is
actually what AOC attacked us at Lincoln
project we were back I don't think they
did anything okay I'm like okay little I
would need to do a little and see the
thing is right he won by he won by a
very thin margin I mean I think what the
total was in what in the 600 000 600 000
votes Nationwide so look if if the
Normie guys the regular they're
conservative they're not big on a lot of
this liberal type stuff but they're also
going to say Jesus Christ man my life
was in danger because of that you know I
would say to themselves [__] if I did
that I might actually be in jail for
that reality winner again went to jail
so we just need a few right so look if
we peel off five ten percent that's a
huge number of veterans we had four
pillars that Lincoln for a reason
veterans and military families uh uh
evangelicals women and Latinos and so
those coalitions of the the Trump
Coalition if you will we peel off just a
couple of percentage points
Biden gets reelected and everyone wants
to look for landslides I wanted to win
60 or 40. look man he just needs to win
50 point [__] one
I think I think more importantly you
know what I mean I think I think more
importantly we have to hold Trump to 44
or 45 percent right that's the idea
right if we're if we're going to hold if
we hold him to you know if if we're
actually doing the what the math the way
you're saying is that we can peel off
this vote we can peel off this to vote
we can peel off this vote we hold him
the 44 there's no there's no there's no
reality where Donald Trump becomes close
right that's right and that's a
landslide that's a huge Landslide
numbers are there I I think the number's
there Tony I really do I think the
numbers are there like enough people and
here's and like a sample the reason I'm
good at what I do comms and politics I
do I know people and and I have circles
I have a large Circle and I talk to
regular people uh I've got family
members uh in my my girlfriend's family
for example who are old school
Republicans and they're sitting back
going uh it's just like Tucker Carlson
being on Twitter now guys look yeah my
81 my girlfriend's 81 year old dad boxes
Fox he sure isn't getting a [__]
Twitter account to watch yeah
it's the same thing they're not seeing
this stuff so so again having them off
those platforms having them not speaking
they're sitting back going
nah bro I mean it's just it's enough we
just need those normies those old school
Services say you know what and look I
don't need a joke look in a perfect
world they're going to come out and
force they're going to vote them
everybody's happy but you and I know the
world's not like that I just want them
to stay the [__] home that's right
that's what I was trying to I said that
in the a block I said that in the a
block look there's there's that five six
percent of the country that that would
vote for him if they went to the polls
but what we have to do is make them so
grossed out that they stay the [__] at
home
that's right right turn the [__] out
right right all the time I did a show I
did one of my shows a while back bill
got mad because I said look I don't care
about independence Republicans they're
like oh my God Fred we have to appeal
the independent republic like no I don't
[__] I do not have to actually appeal
the independent because first of all if
you believe people are really
independent right now after watching
before Donald Trump or eight years I
don't know there's the MDMA coming in I
guess because I don't know what you're
smoking
dude the problem is the problem is
there's plenty of Democrats just not
coming
we spend way too much time I just need
to get independence to like us I need to
get older I need Republicans come over
to our side no I need Republicans to
stay home I need Democrats to come out
that's the formula people want it's not
a switch I just need this one to not
[__] vote I need this one to vote
like [__] crazy and so for a lot of
us they fail that they spend too much
time saying well I had a candidate I
worked with not long ago and he was
constantly saying don't bash these
Republicans Fred because we need them to
come out for us dude they're not coming
out for you yes okay yeah yeah they're
not coming out for you okay they're just
the Republicans in your District are not
gonna go you know what I'm going to vote
for this crazy lib who wants you know
gays and ghosts and [__] they're not
gonna do that I just wanted to say wait
wait wait wait wait wait there's people
out there that want gays and goats yeah
that seems like a heavy lift it's a
crazy world that seems like a heavy lift
all the lips don't you know that um but
I just want them to stay the [__] home
right I wanted to say I'm not voting for
her either I'm just you know and then we
got turned gems out my jobs and so too
often we waste too much money doing
things to try and appeal to the other
side now we need to appeal to our side
and that's where we get in trouble
that's where you have problems like uh
McCall uh McCall was McAuliffe right up
in Virginia McCall didn't lose because
of CRT and Suburban moms flipping their
vote no McAuliffe lost because he blew
off about a hundred [__] counties at
outstate Virginia thinking that that he
didn't need him right he lost because he
did no youth photo or turnout like I
have youth photo organizations that
reached out to his campaign so we want
to help and they didn't call back to a
week for the election and so he had weak
ass young voter turnout he had terrible
anorexic turnout in rural counties look
the difference between 20 turnout of
Democrats in in in the mountains of
Virginia versus 30 uh turnout in those
same counties is Governor versus losing
right because if you give up 30 counties
at Five Points a piece you lose
statewide right right this is why I had
um I had John Nichols from the nation on
my show the other day and he talked
about
I suck at names the Supreme Court
nominee you second names you should try
over here with me it's like my Achilles
by myself
yeah just just do it just mispronounce
it own it I called Matt I call him Matt
Getz and I just thought that him on
purpose
so but she ran her State she won that
supreme court because she ran everywhere
she did rural radio ads on the country
targeting she's stuck to a liberal
[__] you know abortion abortion
abortion ran ads everywhere so in
counties it would have been 20 down
versus 80 they ended up being 30 versus
70. that's all
yeah so again I go back to the topic
Independence Republicans go ahead be mad
stay home but we need damage to be fired
up strategic outrageous yeah yeah and I
mean I would say in the last two
elections alone we've seen how much
like every single vote matters right
like you know look at look at Lauren
bobert's election in Colorado right now
she is 547 votes exactly the next
election she will be I mean like you
know she
I I I have uh I have faith in the people
of the Rifle Colorado area that that
there will be more people supporting you
know
um her opponent than those who uh backed
her impeachment of Joe Biden recently
because I think it was like what three
people back to impeachment right so but
it really it really does like every
single vote matters and Tony and I say
this every single time
you know what it was the general
election it was the midterm election
like these we think like oh well you
know what I live in a blue County or
live in a blue state or whatever it
doesn't matter right it it matters that
you show up and you vote right because
it's statewide right exactly and it's
also it really matters it matters 100
because it's not only just like oh well
I'll show up to this one oh this next
one it's gonna be I mean like if you
look at how the polls which are getting
are Antiquated and how they have things
laying out you know Republicans like oh
it's gonna be a red wave right
and you look at what we're what we were
able to accomplish to just Whittle it
down to just a handful of House Seats
right but it's not just like oh it's
this one election it's creating a habit
right it's creating a pattern of showing
up that one election bringing a couple
friends that next election then bring in
a couple friends the following election
bring in more friends right it's it's
creating uh uh a habit of showing up
voting and not only that but just like
texting a friend and be like hey you
going to the poll today let's carpool
yeah so Fred exactly so Fred before I
let you do a a Shameless plug because
I'm gonna let you do a Shameless plug
here I've got a very important story
that I've got to ask you about here and
my question is do you think Tom Fenton
is uh he's got really bad boob sweat and
this one or do you think this is a brawl
that he is wearing underneath he said it
was Photoshop well let me know
Tom's sitting here with the latest on
the pending indictment of President
Trump by the corrupted Biden Justice
apartment over the fake documents
Scandal that's been used to harass and
abuse Trump I'm just trying to figure
out is that a brawl he's wearing what is
it I don't know it kind of just hey this
seems like important stuff it seems like
important stuff
I don't know it kind of it kind of looks
like uh like he was dealing with the
same stress or uh didn't have the
antiperspirant you know the same the
same thing that Ron DeSantis had in
Florida or wherever wait wait wait wait
wait are you saying are you saying
Disney deodorant DeSantis needs
deodorant does that we work in DC I I I
used to work at DC and I go to me in
June I'd be I had to I had to go to you
I went to a thing on Capitol Hill I had
to go to a ball one of those military
balls that night I had to go to use
station buy an entire [__] new shirt
and time
because I actually like this wet mess in
my my colleague my vice president
Michael's like yeah bro I'm not letting
you go to an event looking like that you
know so yeah
so you're saying so you're saying this
is possible boob sweat okay okay well uh
go ahead and give us give us your
Shameless plug without the sweat without
the boob sweat give us your Shameless
your Shameless plugins
FP Wellman on the Midas touch network uh
we're on to moxie pod on Twitter and of
course I'm FP Wellman uh Frederick Paul
Wellman everywhere you go I can find you
there I'm also doing a really cool thing
I just announced on last week's show you
guys which goes what we were just
talking about which is working on the
idea of funding every candidate that's
running for congress so every Democrat
came you know last cycle we had 23
ripogos ran unopposed we had 149 excuse
me 126 uh Republicans who had
underfunded opponents in other words
their opponent in a congressional race
never going to raise 200 000 which is
considered the threshold to run a
congressional race so believe it or not
149 of the Republicans for congress ran
essentially unopposed last cycle and so
what we're trying to do is trying to
raise raise money to cover the
crowdfunding kind of thing so you give
money it gets to multiple candidates so
every candidate is raised up and so
we're so it's called The Forgotten
Democrats we're launching in the next
week people can find out more
information by texting Fred to
33377 so
333-77 text Fred to that number and uh
you get on our email list and I'm really
excited about doing they're gonna be the
national chairman to try and see if we
can't help more congressmen uh more
democratic candidates get the support
they need run run good campaigns again
we talked about run everywhere yeah well
thanks Fred for all the work you do
that's
forgottendemocrats.org right am I
correct on that forgottendemocrats.org
go follow Fred on Twitter uh that we've
got the link tree down in the
description below so you can find all
the links to a show uh and all those
links thanks for coming on thanks for
all the work you do uh we'll we'll talk
soon my friend good talking to you guys
it's great that's great everyone sit
around we'll be right back with some
more boob sweat stories I'm sure right
right after right after this we'll be
right right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show Fred Wellman
forgotten excuse me
forgottendemocrat.org
you got it you got it
now below thread of the show listen to
your show download
I mean he didn't tell me anything I
didn't know about to go classified
documents I figured um what a mango was
saying about it was all [__] anyway
so that was a pretty good guess right
yeah
yeah it was great yeah but I'm glad it
came on he gave us a breakdown of the
classified information the other thing
that he really uh did Clarity for is I
mean it doesn't it doesn't matter
because it's not his documents it's not
his personal documents and it actually
says the exact opposite in the
presidential records Act of what they
wanted oh but that's great I mean Fred
Fred Fred Fred helped me uh when I did
my J.R Majewski uh are you on your are
you on your air pods are you on your
airpods yeah no this is the Minecraft oh
it definitely are you on your phone too
is that what you're on I told give me
one second no no no no no no no no no
I'm just I'm just pointing out to the
audience
I'm sure they're gonna say Gabe sounds
different my video is choppy yeah I
don't know what's going on hold on look
I'm sure you on your are you on your uh
vaccine network is that what you're on
the internet stopped working it went
[__] downhill
I don't know what's going on man [__]
crazy [__] well why not here's the
thing why you're trying to figure that
out I've got a great video
um that I found now this gay marriage
what what the f i how am I okay well
it's a little small here on the screen
what the hell I'm not sure why it's
doing this
um to be required let's see if we can
zoom in on this thing nope it won't let
me yeah well maybe no no it's because
it's a vertical video yeah yeah it's son
of a [__] man okay well it's still
hilarious it's still hilarious
Are You full screen right now no well I
mean yeah like this okay yeah now zoom
in there there that that's better I
think that'll work yeah that's better
yeah is that better that's better okay
let's play this marriage
they're telling me I gotta get gay
married uh Bobby no one's telling you
gotta get getting married
I don't remember nobody think
that's fishy not even a nibble
see what these second liberals making us
do before gay marriage is legalized I
couldn't marry any lady I wanted she
cuts it now and I'm stuck here married
to Bobby yep we decided to go ahead and
get it done before the government made
us do it yeah you still got the gun we
got rid of all the guns though that's
the next thing the government's going to
come after ain't that right apparently
the man doesn't think it's safe to have
guns in the house when you got a little
kid running around
you guys have a kid
[Music]
they're always
kissing because that's what the
government wants me to do and listen
when I grow up I can be anything
and that sexuality is fluid because
that's the way things are running
anyways yes don't go out and get a good
idea education come back here and take
my job just just another immigrant
taking an American job
they thought you were in your own
business I know I brought a Clank for on
the web mothers you're a doctor we make
love
because Bruce Sun is going to be in a
minute where we have to do it anyway we
better get going it's almost time
what oh yeah we're Muslim now yeah
[Music]
oh my God I can't tell you that's a
great video
when I ah man that's pretty good that is
uh pretty pretty solid mocking right
there oh it's it's fantastic but this is
the arguments that they have though
right like this is oh yeah I mean I'm
surprised that they didn't
uh I mean I there's so many other ones
out there that they're like oh you know
these damn lib turds made us do this and
it's like nobody made to do anything you
know the next thing is like man you the
damn limp turds made us throw out our
gas stove and get electric right we're
even vegan now because they don't want
us even from meat and it's like nobody
made you do that guys
well it's just it's this fear
it's just like self-projected fear where
they're like oh man they're gonna make
us do this thing and we don't have any
saying and it's like what are you guys
talking about who told you this why do
you believe this just take some [__]
Molly man
uh Mary P asked where we can they can
find the video I I retweeted on my uh on
my Twitter but here's what I'll do I'll
see if I can pull it and I'll put it on
like Facebook and maybe I'll even rip it
off I'll rip it off and in fact I'll
make a I'll make a YouTube reel out of
it so that you guys can see that that's
a great video I don't care we'll steal
it why not I'll try to give a proper
credit correct yeah why not hell with it
anyway anyway they're gonna make you do
it anyways
um speaking of dumb [__] then um think
that the government
I I man we only got 15 minutes left I
want to talk to you about this debate
thing I know and this RFK Junior holy
[__] the more you listen to this guy the
more it sounds like uh I don't know Alex
Jones this guy his brain is [__] mush
man why is it
um he's got a condition called uh uh
Speech F uh something I can't hardly
listen to him it's hard to listen to him
it really is and it's you know what I
find you know what I find hilarious is
that uh Republicans are Maga well attack
Joe Biden for having a stutter right or
speak saying a word or whatever it might
be right and like oh man this cognitive
decline and all this [__]
but when you look at they love candy
junior you know he's got a speech
disorder okay so again they both have
speech uh issues that they are dealing
with
and people be like oh man Joe Biden is
so dumb and he's so [__] incompetent
he's in a [__] coma in the basement
on The Lazy Boy
and then they're like oh RFK Jr man this
man is speaking truth get him on the Joe
Rogan get it get him on get him on with
the the [__] CDC get him up with the
doctor vaccine you know it's like what
what do you know what the [__] are you
saying Tim pull all these morons like
I'll put a hundred thousand dollars zip
if this doctor debates RFK Jr which RFK
Jr is a [__] idiot okay the only
reason why they love him right now is
because he is pro-trump period period
he's pro-trump I don't give a [__] what
you saying I'm almost certain Tony
there's a there's a photo with certain
right wing extremist people yeah that
might give you an impression that RFK Jr
is I don't know maybe a plant right
seems like maybe not actually a Democrat
well here Chucky check here and if you
can see his uh his little profile
picture here this [__] guy man this
is the guy who was like oh man we
figured out it was antique but I went to
jail January 6th and then he plays a
video that both Walter and Peter shared
on YouTube themselves
going over to the FBI because they were
like hey man we interviewed Walter and
Walter told us about how the FBI showed
up at his friend's house when Walter was
at his friend's house right the FBI just
showed up unannounced at his friend's
house where you are right this is
ridiculous but Chuck here he's been
posting all weekend Chucky the guy
posting this Twitter Twitter
checky here was posting all weekend
because this weekend was uh training for
National Guard and there was a lot of
National Guard vehicles and stuff out
and about in these different states in
different places uh doing training and
they kept posting videos that they're
invading that the National Guard is
invading what the [__] are you idiots
talking about the National Guard is
invading what us they they're the
they're the National Guard they protect
us they don't invade us they're already
here they forget when the National Guard
had to go into cities in the summer of
2020 like did they not they I'm pretty
sure they they were pro-national guard
then right yes
we're using the military how we want to
uh create uh peace from these cities
that are rightfully and peacefully
protesting and have been proven that it
wasn't then that you know caused this
damage it was actually right-wing
extremists and white supremacists the
Boogaloo boys and all these other
[__] white ring uh white wing uh
[__] but you have people like Chuck
over here it's like oh they're invading
no they're not what what are you doing
but they're but invading where they're
already here the national Guardsmen are
already here like there are Guardians
you're saying but the vials are inside
the computer they are yes they are yeah
they are okay so here's what he says
about Kennedy and this was the this is
[__] nuts that Kennedy actually said
this [__]
he says Justin Kennedy drops bombshell
no more on it's not a bombshell uh but
he says for every life saved from a
vaccine okay get this every life saved
from a vaccine all right
oh [__] it killed four people
okay now listen to the to the logic here
is you are 20 because this is what RFK
actually said you're 21 more likely to
die in six months for taking vaccine
uh wait hold on hold on I got a quick
Point yeah okay well good luck with
logic and reason with these people but
go ahead
if you ever see somebody I think it's
it's a Washington Post article or yes
New York Times I forget anyway
the point is RFK Jr and his children
oh God
they're they're that wait so how many
people is that how many kids does he
have I don't know I don't know if it's
if it here's the thing if it's three if
it's three listen if it's three people
that would be four right
so if it saved him then all his children
would be dead right by his life to
someone else and his right which by the
way you know if people don't know you
know she's the ACT yeah forget her name
right now but she's the she's the
comedian that's on Curb Your Enthusiasm
she plays the wife of
um of uh wow why am I playing on his
name right now well I mean your
internet's internet internet
she she plays the wife of Larry David on
Curb Your Enthusiasm that's his wife
okay
that's rfk's actual wife not Larry Davis
real life white right in real life well
I mean in in rfk's reality in rfk's
reality it's he's just right but I mean
anyway Cheryl Hines as uh people uh are
reminding you thank you so much for that
uh yeah I mean Also let's just let's
just [__] call out the elephant in
the room here the woke
half dead elephant that is you know RFK
Jr um this guy
only has the position he has right now
in terms of like
quote-unquote popularity
is for one is because you know they they
want you know pro-trump people want him
to run you know because he is pro Trump
or whatever
but also it's because his name is
Kennedy but he's unlike anything what
the Kennedys stood for and stand for
right he's only a Kennedy by name he's
Kennedy in name only he's a keynote baby
name only is it Kino or kaino or
whatever
the point is
the only reason that his name has any
sort of relevance or popularity outside
of uh being a plant is because he's got
Kennedy it's not because his policies
are good I mean go to his website look
at what his platform is right I mean the
guy's on Joe Rogan talking about how he
knows more about vaccines and covid than
an actual scientist right this is a guy
that's what happened this weekend tell
people what happened this week in on on
Twitter because Junior goes on to Joe
Rogan and they start talking about all
sorts of [__] conspiracies right
oh it does this and it causes this and
people die from it blah blah all this
stuff and Joe Rogan again Joe Rogan is
very much like a chameleon he will adapt
to whoever is speaking and agree with
him right now if I went on if I went on
he would he would adapt to agree with me
he would do right and and at the
beginning of uh uh right at the
beginning of covid or I think it was
before covid he had um the doctor POTUS
uh
I'm forgetting I'm blanking on his name
the doctor that they want RFK to beat
because yeah I mean I'll be honest with
you I'll be honest with you I've never
heard of this doctor because we're
really not supposed to these aren't I
mean we probably should make them heroes
in our country but we really we don't
know these people we don't know these
people because these people aren't
seeking recognition they're just seeking
the truth right yeah that doctor has
been a guest on Joe Rogan's podcast okay
before the pandemic and they went on
there and Joe Rogan Pro vaccine okay you
can look it up literally video of him
being like Oh yeah vaccines are great
what are they made of mostly saline
fluid in this great they're great
vaccines right a lot of vaccine vaccine
vaccine great then then
you know uh fast forward Spotify deal
and cobit happens and all this stuff you
know later now Joe Rogan is very much
like oh what you know what about these
vaccines
okay Dr Sanjay Gupta was on and even he
was like no you're wrong Young here is
the fact check then he had another guest
on where uh Joe Rogan was like no no
children are getting myocarditis and
because they take the vaccine and the
guy's like no they're not and they're
not more likely to get it if they're
children and he's like pull it up Jamie
or whatever and and the co-host the
guy's off screen pulls it up and they
read it on screen and he's fact checked
in real time and Joe Rogan still in that
moment goes well I don't know it's I
don't know if we can really look at that
I I agree to disagree and he's like you
just you just did you you just said that
you had a point and I and I corrected
you and we looked it up and that was
actual research and you still are like
no no that's not agree to disagree
so this week or this this past few days
he had RFK Jr on they start talking
about a bunch of random conspiracy [__]
you know really diving deep into the
right wing in cell culture the Q Anon
people all that stuff what comes out of
that is Joe Rogan saying Hey doctor do
you want to come an actual scientist do
you want to come on to the show and he's
like look I have no problem talking with
you right and that's what Maga doesn't
realize it's not that he doesn't want to
go on the show is that he doesn't want
to spend his time debating RFK Jr who's
a [__] conspiracy theorist and is
running for president
and so what's happening right now is now
you have Elon Musk saying oh well this
doctor is afraid of uh of of answering
questions and Afraid of the truth that's
hilarious Elon Musk on in April 2020
Elon Musk said this was uh over uh
the numbers were over like inflated he
said that in a couple weeks time now
mind you April 2020 okay we're we're
still in the beginning phase of this of
this pandemic this novel virus that we
don't know much about and we're still
[__] you know running around with our
heads cut off because they're trying to
react to it within the medical community
and uh in April 2020 Elon Musk says oh
you know what
it'll probably be gone in the next
couple weeks right it'll be gone right
just like Trump was like it'll be gone
by Easter
this is what happens when you let idiots
run and have influence of companies
government agencies or the [__]
presidency of the United States okay
this is what happens and so basically
what ended up coming out of this weekend
is that a bunch of people on the right
Joe Rogan Elon Musk RFK Jr all attacked
this doctor right they even had one of
these [__] in-cell Cuts where if you
look at the photo it looks like his ass
is eating his goddamn shorts right he's
got no shoes on he's he knows that he's
going there to harass the doctor and he
says oh are you Dr so-and-so and he goes
oh oh yeah yeah I am you know like
totally caught off guard and he's like
oh why don't you go debate him and and
meanwhile uh you know he's going he's
like uh I'm gonna leave or he's like I'm
gonna go in my house Lee get off my
property right Dr Hotes and uh
this guy I think is Alex Rosen I think
is the guy's name if I remember
correctly and harasses and then he goes
a whole bit where he shows up to the the
police stations like I'm gonna turn
myself in for this the dumbest [__] ever
these people know exactly what they're
doing and they know exactly what they're
spreading and you have people like Elon
Musk who has the biggest social network
uh in in well I don't know I guess
debate on uh Facebook within the U.S but
owns Twitter and uses it for his own
bullying tactics right he goes after the
doctor he goes after uh anyone else who
denies this right you know they're
talking about autism and vaccines and
this and that and it's insane that this
is where we are right now we've got a
guy who doesn't know how to get a
haircut who is talking about vaccines
who thinks that he's uh an
epidemiologist right he thinks that he's
smarter than the CDC he thinks he's
smarter than any sort of coveted
scientist and now he's trying to bully
and after you have Tim pool being like
we'll put up a hundred thousand dollars
if he shows up and now everyone on the
right is like oh he's too afraid he's
not going to show up why would why would
someone on who is a a certified
respected and experienced scientist ever
want to put the time and energy
into debating a conspiracy theorist
because at the end of the day
that conspiracy theorist RFK Jr and Joe
Rogan and Elon Musk and all of the
people on the writer will be like oh
well agree to disagree you'll never be
able to change their opinion right
unless Molly's involved that is true
that is true that is true well let's
listen here is the doctor on MSNBC and
he's talking about Joe Rogan and his
personal experience with Joe Logan well
let's listen to a little of this before
we go contrary to what RFK Junior and
other anti-vaxx nuts have claimed there
is no connection between vaccines and
autism no connection no established
documented connection between vaccines
and serious diseases or mass death
vaccines tend to save lives across the
board do they not that's what the
peer-reviewed evidence overwhelmingly
shows does it not and people are dying
right now from covid still because the
evidence on covet vaccines efficacy is
being ignored or shouted down on social
media
well there's there's three three or four
moving parts to this so um I've been I'm
a vaccine scientist I make low-cost
patent-free vaccines for low and middle
income countries or we made 100 million
doses so we made two vaccine prototypes
that led to 100 million doses being
administered in India in Indonesia no
patents minimal strings attached so we
actually found a way to bypass the
Pharma companies and yet RFK Jr
incessantly calls me a pharmaceutical
when if anything our vaccines may be
kept Pfizer modern out of markets in
India and in Indonesia so I don't
understand that piece and then I the
reason I got involved with RFK Jr in the
first place is I have uh an adult
daughter Rachel who has autism and
intellectual disabilities and wrote the
book vaccines did not cause Rachel's
autism that refuted all of his false
claims and and and that's been you know
he's been uh kind of after me uh ever
since then and now he's at it again and
but this time you know Elon it's it's
the steps sorry this time Eddie it's
it's caused something really terrible
and that is during our coveted pandemic
I have a new book coming out that
basically says 200 000 Americans
needlessly perished because they believe
the anti-vaccine disinformation and
refused to take a covet vaccine during
our Delta wave and be a winning Omicron
wave in 2021-22 after vaccines were
widely available so the point is
anti-vaccine disinformation that's
always done a lot of damage in harm but
now it's a lethal force in the United
States and that's why we that's why we
have to have that discussion and I
offered to come and talk to Gonzo Rogan
again I've been on a couple of times and
have that discussion with it but not to
turn it into the Jerry Springer Show
with having RFK Jr on
we're so it's it's sad because I said
I'm so fed up at the debate need debate
me uh because it's not really about the
debate if it was about finding out
information as you said you've already
written about vaccines and autism you've
already spoken and written about covid
vaccines I think you've been on MSNBC
and other channels hundreds of times
since the start of the pandemic people
can hear your views and the evidence you
bring to this so they're not actually
interested in evidence and it sadden
means that you're a man who basically
has saved lives abroad uh with the
vaccines you've developed whereas RFK
has contributed to a culture of vaccine
misinformation culture that has led to
the deaths as you say of hundreds of
thousands of lives and yet he's the one
being celebrated by Tech billionaires
like musk and Jack Dorsey while you're
being smeared and defamed and I would
say I don't know if you've agreed to
debate or not my advice is not to and
people might find that surprising
because I wrote a book about debate but
I just think there's a time and a place
for a debate I don't think a historian
of World War II should debate a
holocaust denier and it just like that's
that's my analogy here like I don't
think these debates between experts and
cranks do anything other than Elevate
the cranks there you go
um but in another club he goes on to say
that um that he was invited on Joe him
and Joe he seemed like they were good
friends they were kind of personal
friends
um you know he goes on to talk about
that but you know in this debate me
thing
Gabe Sanchez I don't mean to be blind at
this but the whole the whole time this
weekend you know everything was debate
me debate me debate me debate me right
I'll give a hundred thousand dollars to
beat this
but this is the true debate that
everyone wants to have uh debate me
boats I mean
I was like I would pay you for this
debate oh my God oh my God it's
hilarious I mean this debate me bro
culture is so funny because it's been I
mean
it's been around for ages right and it
really got uh it really got a wind in in
2020 when everyone became you know
Dunning Krueger in this cognitive
dissonance and people were like oh I'm
an expert in constitutional law and I'm
an expert in [__] 2A rights and I'm
an expert in epidemiology and I'm an
expert in uh virology and I'm an expert
in uh you know first amendment stuff
right it's like all these things all of
a sudden somebody read some article
right
they scan some uh some right wing you
know Epoch Times article and they're
like I know exactly the position I have
right I did my own research I had I
don't have my hat on me it's in the
other room but uh well here it says I
watched I watched someone else's shitty
YouTube video that's what this means or
what I normally say what it is right
right and these people these armchair
lawyers doctors whatever you want to
call them right idiots
they believe with this highest degree of
confidence which is like it's scary and
impressive at the same time right that
they're able to do and say whatever they
want and be right
and despite all of that they're wrong
100 of the time
like without a doubt no question
absolutely wrong every single time they
open their mouth and they say well
actually no it's no as soon as you said
actually you were wrong right out of the
gate you were wrong do not Pasco do not
collect 200 go straight to [__] dumb
jail
is this Alex Rosen I I don't know it
looks like a guy who would say debate me
bro though right I think this is the guy
that this harassed Dr Hotes at his house
yes I believe so this is that's right
that's right they all look the same yeah
it will no it's it's the dude if you
look at the video of when he harasses
him outside of his house when he's like
coming back in
uh there's a video taken from the back
and I I'm telling you right now if you
look at it you'll notice that his ass is
eating his gray shorts let me see if I
can find it we ain't got a lot of time
yeah but we got time for this
keep going that's maggot right there
keep going
um that is uh if there was ever a
a visual of Maga it would be that guy's
overweight no shoe wearing
dumb Dunning Krueger
ass eating shorts if I had to if I had
to put it down I would say that that is
a perfect representation of a guy who
says debate me bro take me seriously and
shows up with no [__] shoes on
that's what I want to know what the [__]
did what is that why did he show up with
no [__] shoes with just his size he's
a [__] idiot right all of you who are
these seriously bro take me seriously
get some [__] shoes on okay no shirt
no shoes no service okay
come back come back when your mom bought
you a fresh pair of sneakers maybe they
have velcro because you might not know
how to tie your shoes we know you've
definitely don't know how to read look
right here like where are the shorts
going it's like they're getting sucked
into a [__] black hole ain't got his
shoes on right
and he's his [__] pockets are hanging
out and dude he's got swamp ass like a
[__] man I'm telling you man
that dude I mean Tom Finn had some
sweaty boobs but God damn man those
shorts must be delicious the sucking
it's like
it's like if I took my gray shirt this
is his ass right now okay this is his
ass okay what the [__] and it's what the
[__] it's just it's just [__] eating
eating the shorts okay first is sad this
is in Texas right
yeah this is he I think he the the
doctorate lives in Houston yeah Jesus
Christ
did he forget his shoes or do you think
he's he gotta have a car so fast this is
the this is what we're dealing with we
have these people who are almost genius
I read these pieces of paper that said I
was if shut the [__] up man I mean
listen [__] idiot if you saw this guy
if you saw this guy in a fast food
restaurant right and he stand in line to
order
his sandwich right yeah and and if
someone asks you whose podcast do you
think this guy listens to on the rig
you're definitely gonna the top of your
list is gonna be Rogan right
this guy if if you had to guess from
behind from this picture right here it
what podcast this dude is like six four
three hundred pounds right okay Dr hotez
is like uh five I don't know five some
five less than five ten I think or five
ten around there right and he's like a
hundred and something pounds like you're
not gonna be like oh man why was he
running away I don't know because of
[__] huge dudes some weirdo with his
wedding sweating and when you and when
you look at when you actually if you
watch the original video of him doing it
he's like hey are you are you are you Dr
Ho judge oh that's Joker like like ran
over the dude ran over as he's coming
back from like a neighborhood walk
around his block right he's like oh it's
a Sunday afternoon and I'm gonna do what
I do because
I'm just I'm I'm [__] you know
quasi-retired I'm still helping people
out making low purchase
low-cost vaccines for areas that need it
like if there's anyone pro-life it's
gonna be me I'm the one who's saving
lives you guys
are the ones costing lives okay you're
the ones who are costing people to say
oh no I'm not getting it because it's
got a [__] 5G chip in it I'm not
going to do that because they're gonna
make me gay I'm not gonna do it because
it can turn me into a frog right which
is some other [__] that RFK Jr was
talking about this past week and he was
like oh I know these exposures gay frogs
gay frogs I was like what is a frog man
Jesus Christ dude they're [__] he's Alex
Smith uh I want to move on to other
people and it's stupid [__] uniforms
that show up to places
um this is uh again I want to point this
out I know I don't want to uh lay this
um to bed when we have Nazis showing up
at these places and they're dispersing
Republican policy views and open public
when they're doing the the Nazi salute I
think it's the newsworthy to me it is
here is uh here's a bunch of Nazis that
showed up at a story hour where people
were dressed up a costume and covered
their face again yeah well they don't
yeah well that sound happens nowadays
not these aren't I don't want to hide
they hide they hide their faces after
Charlottesville let's let's watch this
oh yeah
I I wonder I wonder if there's children
in this story Arthur if if these uh
Nazis um were scaring them I wonder what
was more scary the Nazis outside in the
costumes or the people that were trying
to teach children how to read and like
how to read and love that reading is a
thing uh in costumes I wonder which
costumes they were terrified of hmm yeah
I would I would go I would go probably
toward the guys who were throwing uh
like an aggressive hand motion towards a
window and blocking their faces like a
monster mommy Mommy why are they doing
those hand gestures well see son in the
1930s there was a murderous dictator in
Nazi Germany that gas six million Jews
and these guys out here they really
support that view not only that if
you're Republican in this country you
also support these views and you may not
think you're a Nazi but these Nazis
Standing Outside The Story Hour they
think you're Nazis oh boy it's so so
convenient so convenient hey your
picture is finally clear now you're
caught up to speed yeah we're oh my God
we're about to go off the air and you
finally oh together I don't know what's
going on dude my internet I don't know
what the [__] happened it's like every
computer I have I was checking I was
like God I gotta connect in and they're
all like
we got no sorry [__] I try to go and it
goes no internet so after we get off
this call like because I'm only running
on I'm running on the sell signal right
now because again you need to run off
you need to run off that gay frog 5G
that you got I know I gotta I can you
know put another put another booster in
I mean everyone knows that libtards have
gay frogs laying around gay frogs and
our 5G chips and our vaccines we have
the we have the good queer beer but
light you know so that we can um so we
can celebrate pride and stuff and be uh
be gay together before the government uh
mandate mandates it and passes amendment
to where we all have to have gay sex
whoa whoa sand date mandate pretty gay
that sounds pretty gay
oh man what a what a great start to the
week we had Fred Willman on we're gonna
have some more guests of course
tomorrow's Tuesday Texas Paul will be
with us I'm gonna try to get Rachel Dr
Rachel bidikoffer sometime this week she
was busy last week with a special
project maybe she'll be able to talk
about it more if we get her on this week
I really wanted to get her her reaction
to the Trump arraignment and the and the
right to reaction to it and what the
political strategy is going to be moving
forward so don't forget to subscribe so
you can watch every single episode this
week as you do every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter
obviously at Tony Michaels pod and
twitch follow us on Twitch as free
follows on twitch.tv Tony Michaels maybe
you can also watch this thing on
Facebook did you know that you just go
to Facebook and follow at the Tony
Michaels this thing airs live every
single weekday on Facebook as well and
then in the afternoon if I don't
um take too long of a nap you can
download this show for free from Apple
Spotify
and Google it's free 99 I also want to
announce
we're coming to the end of pride month
and we had this great design that you
made because Mrs loveseek mentioned in
the chat that they wanted pride pride
[__] em logo and the and the entire
[__] fans like hell yes
so we delivered if you go to
store.dtonymichaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com
you can get 15 off if you use this promo
code it's really easy listen up the
promo code is pride you use the promo
code Pride on store.the tonymichaels.com
and you get 15 off your entire purchase
and we got [__] stickers up there now
so go get your [__] t-shirt your your
fanny pack and grab some stickers to put
on your your Maga I don't know you put
them on manga cars you know you see like
a slap them on any place you see any any
Trump bumper sticker boom Pride [__]
[__] them
Pride [__] [__] them so again go to
store.the tonymichaels.com using the
promo code pride and you'll get 15 off
until the end of the month I set it
until the very end of the month so from
now until then so if you've been wanting
to get something on the merch store
Now's the Time 15 off man you're gonna
get a hell of a deal because it's the
entire store not just the pride stuff
it's the entire store but again go to
store.donymichaels.com get 50 percent
off be used to promo code Pride I can't
wait till tomorrow Texas Paul's gonna be
on we're way over time I'm glad you made
it even though your your Internet sucks
I'm glad we did yeah I got to figure out
how to fix that right after yeah well
all right well I'm Gonna Let You Go and
we're gonna let the audience go same
time same place tomorrow
sir what's up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon